Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 22nd, 2016 was
going on our wow. Yeah.
Um, once again,
I got a computer issues here that I gotta get fixed when I get back to Los
[inaudible]. I am in, um, to Seattle, Seattle,
Washington right now, which I gotta tell you, man, if you come to Seattle in,
in May or June when the sun is out,
it's like you want to live here.
It really is one of the most beautiful cities in the United States.
If you can just deal with overcast skies from like October through April and um,
these people pay the price, but when the sun comes out,
it's fucking unbelievable. So I'm here with Nate Craig,
who's been crushing it this whole fucking tour. And um,
we just went out to get some AIDS, like a couple of tourists. We go,
you want to go down to the fishermen place where they're throwing the fish and
everything. So we're like, yeah.
So we start walking down there and of course it's mobbed. And I say to them,
I go, you realize that nobody from Seattle fucking goes down here, you know,
unless they're on like a first date or you know,
your dad and mom had taken you down there to go see it,
but I would think that you would avoid it.
So we didn't go all the way down and we just Kinda kept walking.
We got a little bit.
Um,
yeah, we walked along that main drag and we just got a little bit away from it.
And,
and um,
after waiting into that sea of fucking humanity, I was literally like, dude,
I will eat mediocre food if I don't have to stand in a line that can actually
sit down like a human being.
Um,
I know the food is good, but I don't,
I just don't understand just standing there like a fucking bread line.
Like it's the middle of a war or some shit. All right.
You live in the United States of America.
We don't stand in fucking line for food.
We want to lower fat asses up.
You just handed to me so I'm not going to name the place,
but I went to this place. It was, it was happening.
Break the bread fucking stunk. You know what I mean?
How do you make fucking king crab only taste. Okay.
You know how you have shitty bread. Other than that, it was a,
it was definitely a good time. And um,
okay,
such a beautiful city. Despite all the dirty white people up here,
there's a major fucking, you know,
I want to avoid using the word grunge.
I think that was just a nice way that did just stick fucking,
there is some dirty fucking white people up here. I don't,
I don't understand it. Just there in Denver. Those are the two,
the two filthiest white people that actually have money. Like your,
you have too much money to be that filthy. Like when you go to Denver, Eh,
those fucking dreadlocked like man Sandal wearing like always looking like you
just got off a fucking one of those blow up tubes, you know,
smoking, you fucking whatever the whatever that doing out there, you know,
carry on print type of shit worse than San Francisco.
I don't mind any of those styles. If you, if he obeyed me, it's 2016.
Jesus Christ, I'm up here. It's not like they're like, uh,
it's probably just me being an old man.
I can't honestly say none of them smelled, but they just, they look like a,
you know, you wouldn't want to borrow anything that they used.
Why am I starting off this? Me, I started off so nice.
I was saying how beautiful it is. It's such a,
the layout of the city is fucking perfect. And, um,
they, even within new stadiums that they made,
like I actually am old school as far as I loved it back when they just had the
kingdom, you know, and they had that great like, uh,
Seattle Supersonics had like, you know, the, the skyline,
I know that they had the space needle and I believe they had the kingdom there
unless it was supposed to be key arena. I have no idea. But those two, um,
arenas, um,
were and are two of the coolest places ever.
I saw at Seattle Supersonics game there, uh,
the last year they were there and it was Kevin Durant's first year somewhere.
I Dunno, I have a picture of him in the Seattle Seahawks, a CLC of Seattle,
Super Seattle Sonics, I should say. Um, uniform.
And then back in the day when I was just doing college gigs,
traveling the road by myself, um,
driving a Chrysler Chrysler cake, um,
I went to a game, uh,
Seattle Mariners game at the Kingdom and Ken Griffey Jr was still on the team.
So how long ago was this? Was like the late nineties,
possibly early two thousands. I forget when he went to the reds. But, um,
I deliberately,
I bought us one single center field seat and I got almost like the front row.
I think I was the second row.
And this is some sports fan geek shit.
I sat there cause not only do I want to watch Griffey play,
but I also wanted to like every night on sports center,
whenever they showed a game at the kingdom and somebody hit a home run,
there was like this weird little runway. Like I'll wait,
you'd see people chasing after the ball. And I wanted the opportunity to, uh,
to do that, which I did all by myself. I didn't get the fucking ball. And,
um,
so whatever. Um,
but having said all that,
if you ever visit Seattle in May or June and it's all sunny and you're like,
oh my God, I could live here,
make sure you come back in like January or December as some one of those
fucking, you know, I understand Kurt Cobain now
one of those months. But anyways, we're uh, we're performing there tonight. Uh,
I'm recording this podcast Sunday afternoon cause, uh, I gotta get back.
Okay.
And Go back to the writer's room working on episode five,
everybody five on a number 10 and a, once we get this one done,
it's all downhill from there. Uh,
really excited about this episode and I don't know,
I'm hoping you guys are gonna like it. But anyways, um, so big,
uh, thank you to everybody who came out into Edmonton last night and went out to
Calgary. Uh, Calgary
might've been the best sound I've, I've ever heard at a show.
I was standing backstage and Nate Craig was onstage.
I mean the backstage here.
And usually in most venues when you're standing to the side of the stage,
you can barely understand the person, just the way the sound is bouncing around.
I'm sure it's fine in the house, but like, um, you know,
so many times I'll be with Bart,
nick or Versace or something and literally just be like, dude, Ga,
that new bit bit I did about blah, blah, blah. And I was like, you know,
I was trying to, but I couldn't quite hear it because of the sound. Um,
okay.
I was standing almost like directly behind.
We're behind and behind the curtain when Nate was on stage and I could hear the
guy absolutely perfectly. And
um,
it was just fun. It was fucking awesome. It was just a great Gig,
both of the gigs.
Um,
and then the next day, you know, we got up, we drove up to Edmonton,
which believe it or not, I've done that drive like three times. And um,
just beautiful, beautiful fucking country up in Canada. Absolutely gorgeous.
I would go out of my fucking mind. I think if I did the road enough though,
if I just flew to other places and then I could come back,
that's how I really did view all these places, you know,
that are considered the middle of nowhere.
They're like these paradises but I think I would lose my mind if all I did was
live out there. Like I understand that people, when they come up to you,
they're like, oh my God, I want to get outta here. You know,
this is the middle of fucking nowhere. And I'm always, you know,
coming from la where everybody's living on top of each other and we have no
water and shit. I'm like, dude, you are living in the garden of Eden. Okay.
This is as good as it gets as far as, um,
natural resources for seasons and that type of shit.
Although what's cold as fuck when we were up there, it's for May anyways.
I mean, the last night in Edmonton was actually sleeting fucking crazy.
But, um,
we ended up driving obviously up to Edmonton and that night at the Gig,
this might've been the weirdest fucking venue I've played in a long time.
It was essentially, I took a picture of it.
It was essentially a giant tent that had a little bit of an upper deck in the
back. And um, there was no carpeting.
Yeah.
Like behind me, they didn't, yeah,
he had all this fucking equipment for the lights and everything and they
usually, they, they dress it up,
they put a curtain there so people don't have to look at it. But they did.
And it was like this giant eyesore behind me and I was standing on like this
concrete slab that had no, no carpeting,
no nothing. The floor was all concrete. They just had chairs,
the sides of the walls. I didn't know what they were made up.
All I know was I was on stage.
I felt like I was like screaming in a giant garage.
Like I, it seemed loud to me, but I couldn't tell if it was loud.
I didn't see anybody complaining where like my ears are kind of ringing today
and I've got a couple of tweets. People was saying like, like, dude,
you sounded like you were yelling into a megaphone, into a microphone.
So my apologies. I wish somebody had mentioned something on one of the shows.
I would have toned it down. But sometimes when you're up there,
you can't hear yourself. But I ended up, um,
I sent a picture to Nia and now I can, should've had the tweet,
other t a the message she sent me,
the text that she sent me, she said that looks like a venue where one of those,
those fake televangelist, you know,
have plants in the crowd and they go to like cure them and shit. And um,
I'll post a picture of it. And as always, I always say, I'll fucking do it then.
I never do, but I'll, I'll try to do it this time. You know what, whatever,
if you follow the MMP on fucking a on Twitter, maybe it'll be up there.
I have no idea. But I'm, before I go any further,
I forgot to mention, um, the all things comedy network is really a doing well.
I, cause I'm a terrible businessman. I never bring it up, but um,
we got some people to invest in it.
We're going to start creating some more content, uh,
content and that type of stuff. And um, you know,
really tried to join forces with other comics and hopefully, uh,
make some comics some money off of that thing.
And get you guys some good comedy. Everybody works.
We keep the big Fuckos out of the wake, you know, are very, at least, you know,
keep them from taking the rights of everybody's fucking shows. You know,
that always seems to be like the business plan. Like, okay, yeah, we'll invest.
All right, we own everything. You work for us. You go fuck yourself.
We'll sleep in bed and make mailbox money and you'll be on the road when you're
90. Sound good. No, it doesn't. Well, it's going to be good exposure.
It's what they always say. Funny young comics out there.
Anytime anybody tries to pay you when exposure,
anytime they say it's good exposure, that means you're getting fucked
up. All right. Also, this Thursday I'm doing a, a charity show.
Um, this Thursday, 8:00 PM at the comedy store,
100% of the money goes towards helping children who are fighting cancer,
um, to have as normal of childhood as possible while they're going through the
treatment and all that. Uh, the tickets are available at the comedy store.
After the show, we'll uh,
we'll put up a link for anyone who can't make it if they want to donate. Um,
Steve Simone puts the thing together and um, he's been doing great things.
He's been having comics go to hospitals and stuff like that. This,
this is a charity that I can get behind,
which brings me back to the mysterious red nose campaign.
So, um, a bunch of people were looking into that,
found it very vague and now I guess it helps out poor children.
That's why you have the clown noses,
which is hilarious to me cause I think it's pretty much mainstream knowledge
that clowns kind of scare the shit out of most children and a lot of adults.
I just don't understand why you got to have this stupid clown nose.
What are you going to do with that fucking thing other than just throw it out
and then it's going to be, you know,
it's going to end up in the fucking ocean and then back in the fish that you
eat. It's so fucking dumb.
Okay.
Like it's not enough to just say, listen, we are helping out poor children.
Do people still say, Nah, I don't want to do that. And you gotta be like, well,
what if we give you a little red nosy nose? And you're like, okay,
that sounds like a good idea.
That's such like a fucking, I don't know.
I think it's like a hacky charity thing. It all started with the, uh,
I think it was the aids ribbon was the first thing,
or was it the quilt and then came the Lance Armstrong live strong things.
Right. And I don't know, somewhere in there was the super finger.
I have no fucking, I don't, I don't, I don't pretend to know these things
anyways. What am I, what the hell am I on my own?
So this fucking new thing is driving me nuts.
I'm so used to not having to look at these fucking
is garageband shit. Um, Oh, here's a nice, creepy thing.
It's really not a nice, creepy thing. It's just sort of a fucking creepy thing.
So we rented this car when we drove up from Calgary to drove up to Edmonton from
Calgary and we had the thing actually picked it up at the airport.
And, um, yeah,
we were driving over to the casino. That's what it was, driving over the casino.
And I find, I just look on the dashboard. I'm like, what the fuck is that?
What does that on the down? I'm like, is that a camera?
I think it was a camera and I think it was pointed at us cause there was nothing
in the front. I don't know if it was the gps antenna.
I Dunno what the fuck it was. But it was really creepy.
So I of course through a fucking newspaper over the goddamn thing.
And um, when I got back to the hotel,
I looked up about cars and cameras and I found this article here, it says,
is your rental car company spying on you and you're driving,
here's how they do it. All right. Rental car,
giant Hertz has admitted it is,
it has cameras installed in about one in eight of its cars in the United States.
But those cameras built into Hertz is never lost.
Dashboard assistant that offers routing help and local city guides have never
been turned on. Give me a fuck. It really,
you spent all that money and he never turned them on.
Your Lion Con's Hertz is said loudly and repeatedly.
They've never turned them on.
Understand that never lost six was launched by Hertz in early 2014.
The product has been out there for over a year and only now is it causing flat?
Probably because most renters began noticing a creepy camera pointed at them.
I'm understand too.
There are excellent reasons to worry about car rental companies sparked, uh,
companies spying on drivers. Um, but very probably never lost.
Six is not one of them. Hurts. Said his last. It has,
it lacked the bandwidth to use the cameras anyway,
but it has been so scorched.
But in sports so severely in the media flap of the past week,
said industry experts indicated that hurts now would be just about the last
company to spy on its customers.
Does any of that make any sense that you'd put a camera in there and then you
wouldn't use it? You'd install a camera and all?
We're just a little mom and pop place. We don't have the fucking bandwidth.
Ford, some of this shit's funny.
They actually find some people like hundreds,
sometimes thousands of dollars using this shit and basically,
you know when you rent a car and they go, okay,
you've got to stay in the tristate area or you're not leaving California. Right.
Some fucking guy. He ended up, he left California,
went to Nevada and then Arizona and then they gave him a a,
I dunno where the fuck it was.
He was slapped with a bill of $3,405 and 5 cents by adding $1 per mile to each
of the 28 74 miles.
He had driven because he had crack cross the California state line into Nevada.
To me that's funny. Okay. Because that guy's a piece of shit.
He lied to the car company. All right.
I'm not just saying hertz is a piece of shit.
People who buy rental cars and they treat them like shit are also pieces of
shit, but I don't, I don't,
but to sit there and film people and then you know they're going to start
recording conversations. Do you want to stand like in the future?
Okay. You go to run for president? Like what could like
bring you down is some fucked up thing.
You said some argument you had in the car with some girlfriend you're not even
with 20 years earlier and they just bring that up in the middle of the debate.
Like I think in the future like they lit it like once you become a public figure
they will just have on a disc, you know it's all going to be logged.
Anything you ever fucking did like questionable shit.
Good Shit that you did all the balance. You know,
they'll probably just have like a pie chart. Okay. His, his life disk, you know,
and the good stuff is in whatever green or yellow man, right.
All the nice friendly fucking colors and then the bad shit will be all in like
red.
Um,
I don't know. If you're prone to depression,
there'll be like some blue in there and they'll just look at the big pie chart
and try to judge it. Then overall what kind of a fucking person you are?
It's just, it's, I dunno, it's really creepy.
This is another one that was funny to me. It says in, in Florida,
rental car companies are notorious for literally shutting off engines of cars
that crossed straight state lines.
The cars may be restart started upon agreement to pay the new fees.
Yeah,
that's fucking hilarious. And here's my question.
How do you know they're not in the left lane doing 90 miles an hour with
somebody on that bumper? You just going to shut off the car,
but you have to wait until the car stops. I would like to think that,
but, um,
I dunno. Pardon me.
I don't mind if they track you with the gps as far as that.
And if you leave the state lines, I mean that's only fair.
You fucking lying to them and the technology exists,
but that's shit to start recording conversations and uh,
videotaping you is like, I dunno man,
that really crosses a line.
Um,
I dunno. Some people say, well,
what about all these assholes texting and driving. They're there. You know,
they're killing people in that type of shit that there has to be a better way.
What do you guys think this gotta be a better way to keep, I mean,
I don't know how safe you have to make the world. I mean,
there's too many fucking people. Can you let some people die? I mean,
I know that's really morbid to say that shit, but, um, I dunno.
I'm kind of a fucked up person. So why, why, why would you listen to me?
Why would you listen to this podcast? Oh, I know why you're on your way to work.
You're at the gym, you whatever the fuck you doing. So let's, uh,
should we do, oh man, I had a really bad,
yeah,
a bad little social, full par. I have after the Calgary thing,
I was walking over to the hotel and um,
I was trying to get into the elevator cause the ones in the lobby,
sometimes you go through the lobby, you know,
people want pictures and shit like that, which is cool.
But daddy wants to drink.
Yeah.
So I was trying to get through there as fast as I could. And one of the guys,
you know, was that the, you know, one of the, um,
the guys who worked there Sorta, you know,
this elevator door opened and I fucking,
he just sorta told me to come in and I just stepped in from these people and
walked on me and Nate in the promoter and the doors closed as we were going up.
Nate goes, um,
did we just step in front of a woman in a wheelchair waiting for an elevator?
And then it dawned on me, cause I did see her,
but I was in such a selfish moment of I don't want to take any, you know,
pictures or anything. I just want to get back down because the bar was closed.
That's right. And you know,
we had a great night and there's nothing better after a show.
You're all fucking amped up from the excitement of doing it in a went well that
you can't just go back to your hotel room, go to sleep,
you want to sit down and shoot the shit or whatever. So we will, that's right.
We will make it a mad dash to get down to the bar. The foreclose.
Now that's a lie. They were actually keeping an open for us.
There was really no reason for me to do it other than my own selfish things.
I didn't feel like taking a picture. So I ran in there and, um,
that has been bugging me for the last 48 fucking hours.
Nate heard her say something sad, have like said something. Well,
I guess we're not getting on this one, you know, classic,
polite Canadian. So I dunno if whatever fucking reason,
if you're the person pushing the person that wheelchair, my apologies. Oh,
freckles was a selfish cunt there.
I'm literally getting embarrassed telling the story right now, but that,
that legitimately happened and it was me.
I Dunno if my rental car company has video or audio of it, you know,
I'm getting out in front of the stories what I'm doing. All right,
enough of that big brother's shit. Let's, uh,
let's read some advertising here for the week. Um, MV m t watches,
um,
when you're in your early twenties and thirties, money can be tight.
If you're not careful, dressing well concurrently. Drain your bank account.
Like spending 400 to $500 on a department store. Watch.
There's some brand names out there that are charging insane prices for watches
that aren't even remotely worth it. Well,
if you want to look great when you go out,
but still have enough money to buy him or her a drink, check out movement.
watches.com
um,
these watches are really shap originally founded by two broke college kids
movement watches cut the middleman out and their big brand retail markups in
order to give you a stylish watch that's at an affordable price movement.
Watches start at just 95 bucks a watch with the duck department store quality
for a fraction of the price. They're sleek and minimalistic.
A modern twist on a classic style moving has grown organically purely by the
support is like you. So to join,
they're more than 1 million social media followers and get a movement watch
today. Um, here's where you go.
I go to MVMT watches.com/burr and they'll give you 50% off your entire order.
That's M v Michael Vincent, Michael Tango,
watches.com/bar
all right. Ah, doc dollar shave club. Everybody. I love upset somebody.
You truly are that. It's actually Dr Carver's shave butter.
It was easy shave butter, but it's now it's not easy anymore,
but it was always Dr Carver's. I just, you know, I have some sort of
um,
oh, I was kidding. I'm stupid.
You know I was going to say some sort of reading disability. That's a cop out.
No Bill, you're fucking dope. Dollar Shave Club. Everybody.
Dollar Shave club.com has a special offer for new members who join.
You'll get a free month of the executive razor when you buy a tube of Dr Carvey
shave butter. I hate it. I don't like it. Doctor Cabbie's easy shape.
This is the first time they've ever done something
being like this and once you try the dollar shave club.com you'll become a proud
member like millions of others.
One reason is because they deliver amazing razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. It just feels amazing on your face.
You'll get a first-class shave when you use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet. Another reason is the a doctor Q Hobbes ego using
it with the executive razor makes the blade glide gently to this for the
smoothest shave ever. Dr Carver's shave butter isn't your average shave cream.
It's unique conditioning formula and a hot with high quality neutral ingredients
leaving your skin unbelievably still often snooze and right now new members who
buy a tube of shave butter, get the executive Reva for free.
They'd never done this before.
Everybody take advantage of it and it's only available by going to dollar shave
club.com/burger that's dollar shave club.com/burr one more and then we're done.
stamps.com everybody you know trips to the post office are never convenient.
So why get postage right?
Why not get postage right from your desk with stamps.com stamps.com even AUC
gives you special postage discounts. You can't get at the post office,
including FirstClass priority mail express international in more.
You'll never pay full price for postage. Again. Here's how stamps.com works.
Using your own computer and printer.
You can buy and print official US postage for any letter or package.
Then just hand your mail to the mailman or drop it in a mailbox.
It's that fucking easy.
No wonder over 600,000 small businesses are already using stamps.com I use
stamps.com anytime I'm selling posters. Um,
whatever horse shit I'm selling after the show if I can figure out how to use
it. So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bird for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital scale
scale. Don't wait. Get started with stamps.com today.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else, click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburdenedstamps.com enter bar.
There you go. Um, okay. All right.
Let me get rid of all of this fucking copy here so I can get onto the questions
and all of that shit. By the way,
did anybody watch games for war of the uh, st? Yeah,
Louie. Louie, me the fair. They gave the fucking shacks.
Y'All right there. Fred,
I'm not going to lie to you as a complete bandwagon fan.
This is one of the biggest examples of bandwagon fan shit you'll ever see is me
becoming a blues fan. You know, just picking a team, right? And uh,
I, after they lost game two and game three and how great the sharps look,
I was just like, I was talking to my buddy going like,
these guys look like they're dialed in.
I think the shocks are going to win the whole fucking thing. And I'm,
this is just been such a weird series. Yeah.
Like game two, three and four. You know,
it's like sharks dominated two and three and then it's like they didn't even
fucking show and don't like the blues didn't even show up games two and three.
And I'm thinking like, God, the sharks got him figured out.
They're going to make quick work of them. And then the blues show up last night,
it was like fucking game two or three never happened.
So I can't figure it out.
Somebody on Twitter sent me something saying these games have suck because
they'd been so one sided. Um, and I wouldn't argue,
I will argue that they haven't been actually the most compelling games.
They just been like three out of four games has just been that little fucking
kick to the bullets there. So, so we'll see. We'll see. Um,
Isa, I have no fucking clue anymore. I thought I have to two and three.
I was like, not only have the sharks going to beat the blues,
they're going to win the whole fucking thing because I'm not impressed with the,
I mean, I liked the lightning,
but they lost that fucking goaltender and I thought that they were done.
I thought they were fucking done. And now all of a sudden, you know,
the fucking penguins won two in a row and then fucking Tampa cans bough Jesus.
It about two to two. I swear to God, if I didn't know better,
that fucking piece of shit. David Stern is one of the Goddamn NHL right now.
It seems like he wants both of the series to go seven games.
Everybody makes their fucking money, right?
They would never do something like that. What are they? The NFL.
Um, oh Jesus. I'm being a cop being such a, such a Goddamn con. Um,
and I'm sort of paid attention to the basketball. I just don't have time.
And I was really hoping
that the Cleveland Cavaliers were gonna go 16 and o and win a title on two
different levels. One, Cleveland would win a title and all those sad,
sad Cleveland fans could quit with this stupid basset hound faces.
You know what I mean?
Cleveland fans are so fucking sad and so many people just don't even give a
shit. I mean, they just have the loneliest look on their face.
And at least when Boston couldn't win a world series,
New York had the decency to give a fuck enough to trash us,
which was always funny to me. When you really thought about it. It's like,
why are you wasting your time? They were like, Walmart,
get mad at the one mom and pop store up the fucking street,
because we were also trying to sell rakes. Right? Like why do you give a shit?
Um, but no one cares about. I Dunno, Ohio. It's amazing.
The amount of, of musicians, fighters, football coaches,
entertainers,
the list of famous people from Ohio might be the most impressive have out of all
the 50 states. And uh,
they don't get any respect and, but she'd go out there. It's just, yeah, I know.
It's just kind of boring, boring ass state to fucking drive through.
I Dunno, but they're nice people, but I don't really,
I don't know if I have sympathy for Cleveland fans as much as they love
Cleveland. It's like, yeah, well, why don't you live there? Nobody lives there.
It's like a fucking ghost town, I guess. Gradually it's coming back. You know,
who gives a fuck? I just like shitting on people anyway,
so I wanted to see them go 16 and older because it would be great to see Lebron
come back. You know, after all the Cleveland fans who are burning,
burning his jersey when he left, you know, I always thought,
is this the fucking thing ever just to go out and burn somebody?
Jersey is the newest cameras are filming you. It's like,
how fucking old are you?
Are you really this emotionally invested in your fucking team? I mean,
I love sports as much as anybody. I remember when,
what's his face left?
Ray Allen went to the heat and all these Celtics fans were mad. It's like, dude,
that's how we got them.
You know, he started with the bucks and then he fought. He one once.
There's somebody, a players, a free agent,
don't ever give you a heart to the person. I'm telling you,
you can't go 100% in because they re, you know, they got that fucking a,
they got that wonder and I sometimes they stay like big poppy,
but most of the times, you know, they come, they come through town,
they pile on the team, they win a championship,
they start acting like they're fucking magic Johnson and the Lakers or some
shit. Larry Bird, you know, when they're really just, you know,
they're window shopping throughout the fucking league. Um, but anyways,
one of the cool things, if they actually went 16 and oh,
it would be so fucked up
that
the Golden State Warriors, right.
I'm assuming they make it to the finals would go 73 and nine beating the 96
bowls and having the greatest regular season of all time and then losing the
championship game to me would have been, you know,
it's like the fucking 2008 patriots.
It's like they went 16 and oh and like I don't, nobody gives a fuck.
Nobody's ever going to give a fuck about that. Cause I'll 16 and oh does is,
well they went sick. Did they want this? Next thing is did they wait, go,
did they run the table now and then they lost the last one.
You know, something that actually having lived through that,
why would I root that for that? For Golden State.
I Dunno.
You noticed there's something about Lebron that I actually feel bad about the
guy. I feel bad for the guy. I don't know what his, you know,
he never seems to be on strong footing with the crowd.
They always seem to somehow not like the guy and he's out there like superman
every night. Um,
okay.
Who's getting well? We brought it on them. His agent brought it on him.
But that stupid fucking press conference,
you know,
doing his whole fucking life story.
And then you just got to decided to take my talents to south.
She didn't even say he don't even say Miami.
That was one of the worst worded fucking statements ever.
I've decided to take my talents to south beach.
It's like you're going to leave these pound puppy look and sad sacks and
Cleveland freezing their fucking balls off.
You're going to talk about your talent and then you tell them them that you'd go
into the beach.
You know what? I don't feel bad for him. Um,
I don't know. I really like Lebron, so I would like to see Lebron
when one in Cleveland. It's great. He gets it for the city. But uh,
when he does, when it, if he does, I will.
I will really miss seeing those sets at Cleveland fence. That just funny to me.
I don't what it is about him. I don't feel bad from, and when they complain,
I just laugh.
I usually have empathy. That's just something about him like, yeah,
no, it's like cubs, cubs fans. Some of them aren't.
They're still mad at me for that time when I said White,
the white sox fans were real fans and I was just taking a stab in the dark.
I was just fucking around because this guy was talking about when the bears beat
the fuck out of the Patriots in the Superbowl.
So I just did the oldest trick in the book. I just went divide and conquer.
And I just said that white sox fans were better than cubs fans and it worked.
You know what I mean? Years later somebody
look, you know, they're their first place.
What do you have to fucking one of the worst tendencies in the league.
It's like, oh, whatever.
Just go to your stupid game and take your fucking shirt off and act like you're
in the big chill.
Yeah.
Um, anyways, the cubs actually, it, that's,
that's, that's the Theo Epstein fucking saga. You know what I mean?
Like what happened in the red sox after 2004 was then all of a sudden it was
like, you know, when your favorite band is just, you know,
moving up the ladder right there, there.
Okay.
I feel like gradually, you know, you know, they're playing clubs, local areas,
and they start going a little national, then they play big,
and then they get all the way up to their best sell selling album ever.
And what always happens when a band that's been together for fucking 10 years,
they make it to the mountain top. What happens? The whole thing implodes.
Everybody goes their separate ways. Next thing you know,
fucking David Lee Roth is singing just a Gigolo, right?
And Van Halen is singing about dreams with the fucking blue angels.
Whatever happened, I don't remember. I tried to block it out. I was,
that fucking crushed me when they, when they broke up, um,
it was the perfect front man for that fucking band.
I Love Sammy Hagar on everything would come up. Um, anyways,
uh,
you guys are gonna kill me. But I completely forget when I was fucking taught.
What the fuck was my point.
I literally have to sway me. Scroll back up.
What the fuck was I just talking about? Oh, Theo Epstein. Jesus Christ. Um,
Theo Epstein after like 2004, I think everybody wanted the credit.
I think the fucking ownership was like no where the reason the 86 years curse
ended. And Theo's like, well, what about me?
And then there was that weird thing where he kind of went,
he like left for like a week. And I remember thinking like, fuck
yeah,
why couldn't they just get along? You know where we go again?
And then he came back and then,
I dunno when everything imploded when the fuck it did. He ends up leaving.
He goes to the cubs.
I thought he left then decided to stay for a couple of years. I might be wrong,
but he went with the cubs and I think that that was his ego thing.
And then the red sox won it. No, seven and, uh, 2013
I believe. And that was our fuck you feel we can do it without you.
So now I think for his ego,
he's trying to become the guy who ended the curse of the babe and the curse of
the goat. And if he does that,
I mean you'd have to say he's one of the greatest,
whatever the fuck his position is. He's a GM. I don't know what it is. Um,
curse of the gold is so fucking stupid, you know what I mean?
Get your livestock off of the fucking field.
You know,
Chris is the babe was dumb enough. It's just like, no,
we made a bad fucking move. We're not a good franchise.
And we weren't a good franchise. We did make good decisions with the Yankees.
God bless them, did not make good decisions.
That guy was a major fucking racist and just refused until the last,
either way though, we were the last team to, to finally admit,
you know, I guess people from other races are worthy of looking at.
And by then we, even then,
I mean we suck when it was just all white people. I mean, I don't know.
What are you gonna do? Um, so anyways, uh, let,
let's read some of the other questions here. I know I'm babbling this week.
This is a,
I'm a little outside my comfort zone without the microphone in the fucking
headset. So, uh, the will all be fixed by a Thursday.
Okay. Vinyl. Hey Billy.
I was at Madison Square Garden show and I seem to remember you mentioning
releasing it, releasing it on vinyl. Is that still happening? Um, interesting.
You should say that. I have the audio and I'm going through pictures right now.
And um, I am telling you right now,
I am going for big air on this one.
I am releasing the entire fucking show. I'm not editing anything out.
I was happy from the second I got onto the second I left.
It was one of the greatest nights of my standup life.
I'm so happy that I have an audio recording of it.
Um,
Cory Angelo, one of the greatest photographers I've met in this business,
the greatest I should say, he took all the pictures and,
um,
I, if I, if I do this right,
it's going to be a sick ass fucking record. And, uh, I'm very, uh,
very excited to do it. I just have to do it the right way. Um,
what happens is if you want to get into the bullshit of the business is this
happened with the one that I did at Carnegie Hall. What happens is,
is when you put out a standup special you get in business with somebody like
comedy central or Netflix or HBO or whatever, you know,
usually built into the contract is that you won't release any similar material.
Um, that's on the special for a specific period of time. And, um,
okay.
You know, I'm probably gonna do another special in November, which,
you know, I did Madison Square Garden November of last year,
so there's gonna be enough overlap where I'm going to have to wait.
I believe I'll have wait a little bit. Um,
I'll try to get around that because I haven't negotiated yet.
It'd be nice if I could get around and be like, look, it's vinyl.
It's for fucking total comedy nerds. This isn't gonna Really. Um,
but then of course you can send up uploading and everywhere cause everything has
to be fucking uploaded. And then the free,
I'm going to lose my fucking shirt on this, but I don't give a shit. Um,
because I know there's people out there that appreciate the vinyl and that type
of stuff and it's a really cool fucking, yeah.
The thing to have. And, um, Oh man,
I'm going to spend some money on this.
I'm really gonna spend some money on this.
I really want to do this as first fucking class as I can.
And I was actually talking to somebody about it the other night.
I'm somebody who makes records and he was showing me some of the shit that he's
done and I was really impressed. So, um,
I'm literally getting excited talking about it. So, uh,
that's definitely happening when I can actually release the fucking thing is a
completely different story. So, all right. Basic training.
Uh, Billy bloom.
Uh,
you mentioned in a throwback clip that you would only perform for the troops in
the Middle East if you went through basic training and was taught how to kill a
man. Well, at least how to shoot a fucking right
gun. That's like my sphere.
I'm going into a fucking war zone and God forbid it gets overrun by a bunch of
lunatics and my body,
God takes one for me and he's laying on the ground and there's his weapon.
And I'm like, I don't know how to work this
standing there like Bob hope with a fucking potter. You know, I just, you know,
I know the, and they always say this shit too.
We've never lost anyone in all the wars that we've fought.
We've never lost anyone. It's just like, dude, that's just like saying my,
you know what? My car is running great. You don't say shit like that. Anyways,
he said it was wondering if,
if that's as true as it was when you said it in 2008,
I believe you're in better shape these days and perhaps so is the Middle East.
Uh, love you. Love Nia. Um, Nah. Yeah, I think at this point, you know,
look dude, when I saw over there,
like when I was first thinking that that was back when shit was really bad and
like contractors, you know,
wood had a rock in their shoe when they would stop for half a second to get it
out and then they just disappeared. And then the next thing you know,
they're getting their heads sot off.
I mean, one a fucking way to go. I mean, Jesus Christ,
you know what I mean? And I both, so once, one thing I,
one of the reasons why I've been any success that I've had in life is I've
always understood what I suck at. Okay.
And I know I am not a marine. You can give me the camouflage shit. You know,
that dumb shit when people go out and go fucking, uh,
do shows for the troops and they take of
you sitting in a jet or like in a fucking tank and you're wearing a helmet,
you know, and for half a second you egos, I could do this. No,
you can't do that. It takes a special person to be able to do that.
And I know that's not me.
Um, [inaudible]
through Ashley, to really be honest with you.
I wouldn't want to go through basic training because I am a fucking lunatic to
begin with.
And the last thing I need to do is de-humanize any more people in my fucked up.
Right.
Um,
yes I am afraid of, of, you know, to,
to go down that rabbit hole of how fucking, how nuts am I. Okay.
I like to feel that I'm a mainstream psycho, you know,
it's kind of like my drinking. Like I know I drank way too much,
but I have it under control, but I know a couple of circumstance.
Well I'm too, I'm too vain to drink myself to death, but I could,
I could definitely, uh, you know, I,
I know enough not, I knew enough not to fuck with hard drugs.
Um, cause uh, I saw what they did to, you know,
like everybody,
I think everybody in my country at this point at and t for,
I hate to say it at this point, you've, you've lost somebody to that.
And I've lost, uh, two people, two friends of mine outside of comedy,
and then, uh, obviously a number of Comedians to that type of shit.
And I'm both friends of mine and then comics that I was fans of in that type of
shit. So I always knew not to fuck with that stuff,
but as far as going over there, yeah, I would definitely do that.
I would definitely, um, do something like that, but, you know,
when it was really fucking crazy over there and leave your comments or telling
me the way they did,
do those military landings where you like at 38,000 feet and a minute later
you're on the ground. You know, I mean, it's,
it's scary enough landing in San Diego.
I don't need somebody possibly shooting at me.
Um,
yeah. And I'm just being fucking honest. Do you know what I mean? So, uh,
but at this point, yeah, no, I, I will, no problem. You know, Jesus,
if I ever fucking go over there and something happens to me and they play this
fucking audio, you know, they're gonna do it and all those fucking things. Um,
yeah. You know, going to war is, is it's not, that's the real deal.
And I know I don't have that in me fucking go over there with a Hawaiian shirt,
but I am that son going over there with whoever the Marilyn Monroe is there
and she's got this thing and you know,
happy birthday Mr General or whatever the fuck goes.
I have no idea what happens on those shows. But um,
okay.
I know like,
like fucking rd Lange went to like already laying went into this shit in like
Afghanistan, like fucking like crazy.
You would never catch me doing that. That guy's got more balls than,
than I would ever have. No. Um, but yeah,
I'll go to the big base that already has a best buy on it. I'll go to that one.
Whatever military base over there that already has a monorail, I'll,
I'll go to that one. Maybe like an Orange Julius. I'll check that one out.
But I, I would definitely do it without a doubt. All right, a name dropping.
Hey Bill.
Um,
I listened to the podcast every week, which means my wife does as well.
Oh Geez. Not another one of these. I know women hate me. Okay.
I walked in the hotel today and this guy goes,
I didn't know you weren't in town. I said, yeah, you know,
play of theater down the street. And he goes, uh, he goes, oh. He goes, yeah,
I'm definitely going to go. He goes, you know, I'm going to go,
I guess my girlfriend hate shit, but I'm going to go. It's just like, I get it.
I get it. I get it. I'm not going to change what the fuck I do though.
But I understand it. Here we go. Alright, so, okay, here. Here it comes.
How long before I get how,
how much do I have to read before I find out that she hates me? All right,
last week you said you didn't want to write.
You didn't want to name drop your friends name in a band. Um,
this started my wife down a path of questioning and thought,
I'll quote her. Who is bill scared of?
You would think he's still on a playground in waiting to get beat up at the x
out of order. He's Bill Burke. Who's going to give them shit.
Um, she has a good point. I totally understand why you do that,
but you'd have to drop a dozen big names that didn't even matter,
but what,
but you have to drop a dozen big names that didn't even matter into a story
every week for a year. For anyone to think of you
as a name dropper.
Uh, you're the best. Come back to Rhode Island. Um,
you know why you don't do it? Because
people who are in the public eye, there's like this sort of like, there's a, a,
there's an unwritten fucking rule that when you're hanging out with them,
you're hanging out with them and then it doesn't become a fucking podcast story.
You don't fucking tweet about it. You know, you know,
and you don't ask for a picture because that's what their life is.
And I know people that have fucked that up. I've got a buddy of mine,
all right, he was golfing and
ah, he got put in this for some, with one of his favorite actors.
And it turned out the actor was a fan of his and they were having a great
fucking time. All right. Just shooting the shit being normal.
And in the end
the guy goes, yeah, that's great man. I'd love to come out to a show.
And
instead of saying, all right, give me a number. Uh,
I'll text you next time I'm in town. He goes, great. He goes, is it hey, is it,
is it cool if I get a photo? And he said, the guy's face just fucking dropped.
And was just like, yeah, man. Yeah, okay. Yeah, let's do,
I don't want to do that. You book
like, I don't mind, you know,
unless I'm trying to get to a bar before it closes.
Those are only the Times that I bug it. Yeah.
You know, bothers me that somebody wants,
it's, it's way better. Somebody wants a picture than nobody gives
a fuck. But I'm also at a cool level of just being known.
I'm known enough that I can sell tickets on the road,
but like I can walk down the street, nobody fucks with me. Right.
But those people that are at that other level, you know what I mean,
where they can't leave the fucking house, you know,
if you're hanging out with them, you don't go blabbing about it on a podcast.
It's a, it's to put it bluntly,
it's really fucking tacky and it's not professional.
And not to mention you come off like a namedropping cunt, you know,
I actually had somebody do that to me one time.
I fucking had no this shit on me. You know, somebody, uh,
I was having this debate with somebody and then ended up fucking writing
something about it afterwards. It was just like, oh, you know,
I thought we were just a couple of comics hanging out. You know,
I was just like, and just, I dunno,
I just gross is all I thought like that was fucking gross.
Cause now I thought that, you know,
we actually would talk and human being to human being and now you're trying to
get turning into something, you know? I don't know.
It's gross. That's why I don't do it. All right. Um, alright.
Wedding song. Dear Billy Cock ring bearer.
Oh Jesus. He's a, I'm getting married this year.
Okay.
And my fiance and I are trying to figure out songs for the wedding.
You Dig Music, what would you
and the lovely mia m I a it's neo with an n like Nancy,
the lovely Nia suggest for our entrance and first dance.
We appreciate your insight.
Okay.
Oh my God, I can't write,
but the person just wrote Jesus Christ easy with the homophobia.
There said go fuck yourself. Um,
I, I don't fuck dude, I listen to hair metal man.
You don't have to listen to me. I don't know. Something from great white
about White Lion. I'm one of those white bands was,
it was white snake, white lion and great white.
Uh, that's like when they had all the number of bands right. Mary?
Three and four, three 11, some 41.
Uh, that off the fuck they all right. What songs should you come?
I would think the song that both of you guys like, I have no idea.
Uh, your wedding starts. All right.
You coming in.
Okay.
I Dunno. I'd say some from Lou Rawls, lady love,
you know,
although he's kind of suggesting an open relationship a little bit if you really
listen to it. Um, anyways, I don't fucking know. That's a weird one.
I have no idea. I don't know what kind of music you're into.
How about something from Cinderella? Speaking of which, um, from my generation,
um, I just found out the drummer from mega death
died last night. Um,
was it Nick Menza that his name? Yeah,
ex Megadeath drummer.
Nick Menzie collapses and dies on stage 51 fucking years old.
That's it.
Um,
was like three songs and he was at that place, the baked potato,
which I have never been to. It's a legendary music venue.
Like if you ever come out to La and you want to go to a cool music venue and
possibly see some huge fucking musician,
just basically jamming with a bunch of people from other bands or studio
musicians, that's the place to go to. I've never been, I don't know why.
I just always end up being busy having to do a standup show. But, um,
fortunately he, uh, he died, uh, 51, you're going to be 52 years old,
which is a, it is way too young in general,
but when you're going to be 48, next month is pretty fucking scary.
Way off the fucking chicken case of S. Um, all right, here we go.
French music recommendation. Hey Gian lay rouge. Uh,
I know you're working on your French skills and you're always looking for music.
So I thought I'd give you a two, a twofer. Check out an artist's name.
Strong mayor. That's how you say it. Strong mayor.
Nope. Like God, I'm an idiot. Oh my God.
I'm a fucking idiot. It's Straw Mae and then it was dash.
You're welcome. I thought that your was part of it.
I though it was strong mayor, but it's Romae. You're welcome.
Oh my God. What a fucking dope. Uh,
every time I think I find the bottom of my stupidity,
then there's a whole nother floor. Um, anyways,
he's from Belgium and his stuff has a really diverse set of influence,
influences. But besides that, the music is amazing.
Even if you have no idea what the fuck he's saying.
I'm not a native French speaker. Wait, he's from Belgium,
but he sings in French. Anyways, he goes, well,
my family spent some time in Belgium when I was a kid.
I've forgotten a lot of my French over the years and listening to this as
bringing all back to me.
Uh,
it says bone bone shanks, Canard. It's double.
And I know Bernard has duck. So c. O, n. N. A. R. D. I don't know what that is.
Is it?
Probably, if it says good luck, fuck face, I have no dick or something.
I don't know. Come back to New York City soon. That makes no sense to me that,
yeah,
we're in Belgium and you learned how to feed, speak French.
I thought you'd be able to talk to a young club on down the muscles from
Brussels. Right. All right girl. Wow. This guy tried to ride.
Girl is fucking with my head and she's so fucking with his head.
He wrote girl girls if fucking with my head,
a dear Billy bats. Um, a few months ago,
my waitress at a Mexican restaurant caught my eye with her cute smile and warm
personality.
I asked her out and things are going great after two dates we were having sex
and I love spending time with her and making her laugh.
She's also joining the air force and she used to ask me advice because I'm in
the marine reserves.
I didn't see her during her final week and late on Saturday during my drill
weekend,
she was texting that she was a terrible person and she was never going to amount
to anything. Sounds like she fucked around with Anya. I'm sorry.
That's just my paradigm.
I consoled her and she sent a two page text while I was asleep
at 6:00 AM the next morning I woke up to the text that read this has been eating
away at me and I had a few glasses of wine and can't hold it in. Uh,
Eric comes on Wednesday.
I had lunch with my old friend with benefits and I ended up blowing him.
I'm so sorry. I like you so much and I feel horrible the next day.
I asked a few details about the incidents.
Yeah,
we are using your hand to crank in the chef. Um,
I asked a few questions about the incident and said she had a strange way of
showing affection towards me.
I told her I didn't want to see her anymore and deleted all of her contact into
my info from my phone and blocked her number.
Perfect.
Am I being too hard? Is it really so hard to not suck a dick?
I've never had the urge.
She even told me not to cheat on her and then does this.
I probably should've seen it coming because apparently cheat also had a
threesome with two guys. She seemed so nice though.
This is the first time I'd been cheated on in this fucking with my head. I'm 23.
This shouldn't be that big of a deal,
but my confidence took a serious blow here. No Pun intended. Um,
hey dude, you know
that that happened to me at least three times in my life that I'm aware of women
fucking sheet too. All right. I mean, everybody knows that guys are dogs,
but women do it. Fuck it too. All right. And um, how many,
fuck I didn't want to get it. It's just,
no,
the only reason right now where you're questioning it might being so hard on it.
That's just your feelings talking because you miss her. But Dude,
you did the right thing. It deleted her shit. It told the fuck off.
That's a big time. Self esteem move and uh,
you're only 23 years old. You've got a bunch of great women in your future.
Um, I'm not saying fuck her as far as her as a person,
but just forget her as far as like someone that you can have a relationship
with, but you know, she's obviously working out some stuff
and uh, you know, she, you know,
she's on her path. Your on your path and a,
you're not looking for that sounds like
and uh, yeah, just, just move on. You did the right fucking thing. You know,
allow yourself to be sad and go through the shit and all that, you know,
don't do the dumb guy thing where you just try to shut off your feelings,
go through the failings, fucking cry it out of you when no one's around.
They'll make it awkward for other fucking people. And then, uh,
you know, just don't fuck with anybody for awhile, you know,
figure out what the fuck you want to do next. But don't go back Dora.
You can't go back to her. Um, yeah, I wouldn't do that.
Plus, you know, she's joining the fucking air force.
You're going the marines anyways. You know,
you can't tell me this. You can go,
you're going to probably go around the fucking world.
You're going to meet all kinds of beautiful women. She actually made a long way.
She probably did you a favor and I'll tell you right now that is as positive as
I can spin that. Cause I know it sucks. It sucks. You know,
what are you going to do? All right. Um,
sometimes I want it where the hell wasn't as before I wrap this up here. Uh,
people keep asking me about the, uh, the European tour. And here's the thing,
I am not allowed to say what the dates are. It's definitely happening,
but I can be vague about it at this point.
I heard a rumor that it might start
the end of July, like the very end of July,
like maybe the last day of July.
And I heard that it might go through, I don't know,
mid August
like Mo actually August 8th, maybe to the 10th.
It all fucking depends. All right.
Okay.
And the rumor is that it might start in a city that in country that rhymes with
Mumblin fire island and then it might go to a city
that rhymes with a healthcast.
Oh. And then there's another one, a hallway,
Maryland. I'm not allowed to release any of this information.
Then I might go to pistol. Uh, Finland
can fester England,
Munden England Hash Hamster Cam.
Okay.
Federal lands. It, uh,
what the fuck can a routing is that then I go up to f fed borough.
Uh, Hartland possibly.
That might, that might be it. I'm not allowed to say, but, uh,
I don't know when we're going to do this thing,
but I will tell you that I thought I was going to Belgium and as of right now,
if that's not on the list,
which is really bugging me because I really wanted to go there.
So I'm hoping that maybe I can, uh,
we'll see. I mean the amount of cities that we got offers,
um, if I'm still gonna remain married, uh, I have to break it up into three,
three tours. So I think I'm going to do
this one and then maybe I'll do the Scandinavian one with Belgium on that one
and then an eastern European one.
I don't know how long it's going to take me to do all of those,
but I definitely plan on doing them and I'm extremely excited about getting over
there. There's a lot of cities there that I've never played to and um,
I dunno, like I can't wait to get over that. Plus, you know,
it's going to be great for me.
It's gonna feel like a summer vacation because we'll be done writing all 10
episodes ofF is for family. So anyways, that's, um,
that is the podcast for this week. Uh, once again, thank you.
Everybody came out in Calgary, Edmonton and Seattle tonight.
This has been a great three day run. And, um, the arguing,
I gotta tell you Seattle Zoo in all these areas up here,
once you live out in a fucking desert, man, it's just,
I always look down as the planes landing going,
what if I live in that house right fucking there.
You know,
somehow I was able to fucking exist in show business and not live out in la,
which I eventually, maybe we'll be able to do. But then what am I going to do?
I gotta be in the Writers Room.
Um,
eventually I'll be that guy. I'm going to be that guy. Eventually.
I'm going to be living next to a fucking lake in the middle of nowhere
and, uh,
staring at a wall, drinking myself to death. All right, that's it everybody.
That's the podcast. I'm going to watch the, uh, the booze game. Um,
we'll see what happens here and, uh,
go fuck yourselves and I will check in on you on a Thursday. All right.
See you.